Ja, von mir aus, Abi.
Dankeschön.
Okay.
Hallo Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Gürbüz.
Ich bin Assistenz der Tätik in der Notaufnahme.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Geschicht befürchten.
Ist das für die Nordnock?
Weiß ich nicht.
Gibt es da keinen anderen Arzt?
Ja, momentan bin ich die einzige Arzt in der Notaufnahme.
Deswegen muss ich Sie selbst untersuchen, wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind.
Also so ganz einverstanden, wenn ich jetzt nicht damit habe.
Aber ich würde gerne eine deutsche Ärztin haben wollen.
Aber momentan im Haus keine deutsche Ärztin sind vorhanden.
Oh je, Arm ist Deutschland.
Wie weit sind wir schon bekommen, wenn das hier türkische Ärzte arbeiten?
Ja, das ist ein Schichtar von Deutschland ich glaube.
Das ist ja ganz schlimm.
Dann gehe ich aber in ein anderes Krankenhaus.
Ja, Sie können selbst entscheiden.
Aber ja, ich respektiere Sie, wenn Sie nicht die Untersuchung ablehnen.
Na ja, ich guck mal Sie sprechen ja sehr gut Deutsch und verstehen mich.
Aber wohl auch vielleicht können Sie mir doch helfen.
Ja, natürlich werde ich Ihnen entschuldigen.
Wie ist Ihr Name nochmal?
Görbüst.
Ja, genau.
Mein Name ist Friedrich Müller.
Friedrich Müller, könntest du bitte vor und nach Namen bestabieren?
Oh, das auch noch.
Also Friedrich, F wie Friedrich, Richard, Ida, Emil, Dora, Richard, Ida, Cesar, Heinrich, Friedrich.
Ja, stimmt.
Sehr große.
Name ist Müller.
M-U-Dopolel-E-R, stimmt.
Genau, sehr gut.
Und Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 52 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 23.06.1960.
Sie sind 52 Jahre alt, oder?
52.
Ja, aber 1960 oder 1970?
Dann ist das 70, dann habe ich mich wohl verrechnet.
Okay.
Und wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Wollen Sie das alles wirklich wissen?
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist sehr wichtig für die Dokumentation und für Ihre Gesundheit und Behandlung.
Also wenn das unbedingt sein muss, also ich wiege 123 kg und groß bin ich 1,76 m.
Okay, was für Beschwärten haben Sie, Herr Müller?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Also, Frau Dr. Gürbitz, ich habe so eine Schwellung am linken Unterschenkel.
Das wird immer dicker, da jetzt glaube ich eine große Wunde.
Ich sehe das ja nicht so gut durch meinen Bauch.
Und das riecht auch sehr intensiv in den letzten Tagen und ich habe das Gefühl,
das Bein wird auch ziemlich rot.
Okay, ich verstehe, seid man haben Sie diese Beschwärte?
Also insgesamt geht es glaube ich schon seit einem halben Jahr.
Aber jetzt in den letzten Wochen ist es schlimmer geworden.
Also meinen Sie, seit einem halben Jahr haben Sie Schwellung und Wunder im Fuß
und die Wunder riecht seit einem halben Jahr sehr schlecht.
Stimmt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also nicht am Fuß, sondern am Unterschenkel.
Unterschenkel, okay.
Und das Riechen ist erst seit wenigen Tagen.
Okay.
Und die Wunde steht außen des Unterschenkels oder innen?
Ich kann es Ihnen gleich zeigen, das ist vorne am Schienbein.
Okay. Wie groß ist die Wunde?
Können Sie beschreiben?
Also so wie Sie sagen, ungefähr so groß wie ein Euro Stück.
Aber das ist mit der Zeit größer geworden.
Das ist jetzt schon ungefähr so Hand-Innenfläche groß, vielleicht 10 cm im Durchbruch.
Wie Sie sehen, ist die Wunde hat eine so dicke Schicht, eine großartige Schicht.
Die ist hell, die ist gelb und um die Wunde, um ist es ziemlich stark gerötet.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und kommt die Flüssigkeit aus der Wunde aus?
Ich glaube schon, aber es kommt aus der Wunde aber auch aus meinem Bein.
Es ist auch viel dicker geworden in den letzten Tagen.
Also beide Beine oder nur linke Beine?
Nur das linke Bein und ich habe auch zunehmend starke Schmerzen.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen in den Gassen und Techenten?
Ja, ja, ja. Also ich kann schlecht laufen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Seit wann haben Sie die Schmerzen im Bein?
Das ist neulich oder seit einem halben Jahr?
Das habe ich immer wieder gehabt, aber jetzt so wie es im Moment ist,
so stark weiß noch nie, das ist jetzt seit drei Tagen so schlimm.
Wie ist das mit der Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei nun keine Schmerzen sind, sind zerstark Schmerzen in Schipriheten.
Letzt würde schon sein, so 8 bis 9.
Okay, ziemlich stark.
Und waren Sie deswegen beim einem Arzt?
Nein, ich gehe sehr selten zum Arzt. Ich mag keine Ärzte.
Ich verstehe, ja.
Ich gehe sehr ungern zum Arzt.
Haben Sie andere Bescheiden?
Ich meinte, Herr Strasen, Herr Sklopfen oder Brustschmerzen.
Das ist jetzt nicht, aber ich bin nämlich sehr schwach in den letzten Tagen.
Okay.
Ich kann nicht.
Gar nichts.
Ja, aber jetzt in Ruhe auch schon Schmerzen.
Also ich kann kaum auf Toilette gehen, weil ich ganz, ganz stark Schmerzen habe.
Okay, seit drei Tagen meinen Sie.
Haben Sie Atemnot auch?
Ja, ab und zu, aber nicht so schlimm.
Aber ich bin sehr schwach.
Haben Sie interliste Zeit, gebet ab oder zu, genomen?
Nein.
Waren Sie interliste Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein. Ich war immer nur hier.
Treiben Sie supportregelmäßig?
Ich will bewegen, dass ich beschwerden, nein.
Das wäre schön, aber nein. Sport ist nichts für mich.
Für Sie ist ich fibrig?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber es könnte schon sein.
Also das Bein ist schon sehr warm.
Da wird aber bei mir noch kein Fieber gemessen.
Ich habe über Thermometer, Frau Doktor.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich werde die Körpertempore tun, das ist keine Sorge.
Haben Sie interliste Zeit, getroffen?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern, nein.
Haben Sie das Bein nicht geschützt?
Nein.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Haben Sie Schmerz mit der Gegend?
Nein, ich habe nichts gemacht.
Ich habe noch nichts gemacht.
Ich mag auch keine Tabletten.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlösen oder Schmuck?
Nein, das klappt ganz gut.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich schlafe die Nacht und manchmal auch tagsüber.
Okay.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine, Bluthochdruck, Blutstücke oder Asma?
Ja, Frau Doktor, das habe ich alles.
Ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck.
Ich habe auch einen Diabetes.
Seit viel Jahren Diabetes.
Seit vielen Jahren Diabetes.
Seit 15 Jahren, glaube ich.
Und Bluthochdruck, auch seit 15 Jahren Diabetes?
Das habe ich schon länger.
Das habe ich schon seit über 20 Jahren Diabetes.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Chronikungen?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Frau Doktor hat mir schon einiges gesagt.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich mag keine Tabletten, deswegen gehe ich auch sehr ungern zum Arzt.
Ach so, okay.
Ich nehme nichts, wenn ich mich gut fühle.
Ich nehme nichts ein, weil ich denke, da ist der Blut in Ordnung.
Okay.
Ich verstehe welche Tablette oder welche Medikamente ich nehme.
Oh, Frau Doktor, da fragen Sie mich Sachen.
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen, wie die heißen.
Das waren so kleine.
Die Packung war so rot-weiß.
Und die Tabletten waren auch so hellrosa.
Okay, okay.
Ich verstehe.
Und messen Sie Ihren?
Sie können gerne meinen Hausarzt fragen.
Natürlich, ich kann mit Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren.
Und können Sie selbst Ihren Blutdruck oder Blutdruck messen?
Ja.
Hab ich aber auch schon lange nicht gemacht.
Okay.
Also Sie wissen nicht, ob Blutdruck und Blutdruck gut angestellt sind.
Ich denke schon, ich habe da keine Beschwerdenbescheher,
aber ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wurde Sie schon mal operiert?
Ich überlege, ja.
Ich hatte mal Gallenblasensteine.
Die haben sich entzündet.
Und dann hat man mir die Gallenblase entfernt.
Was war das?
Ich glaube, das sind so fünf bis sechs Jahre her.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und woher ist die andere Operation bei Ihnen durchgeführt?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Okay.
Gallenblasen entfernt und komplikationslos verlaufen.
Das ist gar nicht so eine Problem.
Ich musste einige Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Das ist sehr gut.
Okay.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, nein.
Nein.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Also,
das haben Sie beschwerden.
An sich nicht.
Nein, ich kann.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich rauche so ungefähr halbisch acht.
Seit meinem sechzehnten Lebensjahr.
16. Ja. 16, also ungefähr 30 Jahre. Ja, wenn Sie das so rechnen, ja. Trinken Sie Alkohol? Ja. Und was trinken
und wie oft trinken Sie? Oh, muss nicht viel. Ich trinke so morgens eine Flasche Bier, dann zum
Mittagessen noch eins und abends vielleicht noch ein bisschen Wein dazu. Okay, zwei Flasche Bier und
ein Flasche Wein, ein Glas Wein täglich. Ja, manchmal auch mal mehr. Okay, wie oft trinken Sie mehr?
Das ist nicht viel, Frau Doktor, ne? Das ist ja immer nur eine Flasche. Ich kann nicht so sagen,
das ist nicht viel für die Gesundheit und ich empfehle Ihnen, Sie sollen ja Alkoholkonsum
reduzieren. Ich trinke keine harten Alkohol, wissen Sie, ich trinke kein Wodka oder Whisky. Ja,
das ist ein Naturprodukt. Ja, stimmt, aber Sie trinken täglich mindestens drei, vielleicht
auch das Glas Alkohol. Ja, ein Glas geht, aber mehr nicht geht. Okay? Ja, meinen Sie? Nein, schauen wir mal.
Okay. Und Hermülla, nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage, nicht per se, nicht, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen? Mit Drogen? Ja, genau. Nein. Okay, das ist gut. Was machen Sie
beruflich, Hermülla? Ich bin Postbote, nicht Tage, die Briefe außerhalb, ein Briefträger.
Sie sind Postmann, stimmt. Ja, das nennt sich Briefträger, Frau Doktor. Auf Deutsch nennt
sich Briefträger. Okay, ich verstehe. Und Sie sind verheiratet? Sind Sie verheiratet? Nein.
Leben Sie alleine? Ja, ich habe noch eine Freundin, aber ich lebe alleine.
Haben Sie Kinder? Nein. Okay. Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit? Ja, natürlich immer wieder.
Das ist schon ein stressiger Beruf, man muss halt immer rechtzeitig die Briefe austragen,
schauen, dass sie auch immer pünktlich ankommen. Das ist schon viel Stress, ja. Ja, ich verstehe.
Und, Hermülla, leben Ihre Alten noch? Ich weiß, ich habe sie schon längere Zeit nicht gesehen,
aber ich meine ja. Okay, ich verstehe. Und, Hermülla, sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Gegen Corona auch, ich meinte. Gegen Corona? Wissen Sie, diese Corona-Geschichte ist ja
wirklich, denke ich, nur ein Spiel. Ich lehne die Impfung ab.
Und dagegen habe ich mich nicht impfen lassen und will ich auch nicht. Okay, ich verstehe. Ja, das ist Ihre Entscheidung.
Und die anderen Impfungen? Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, ob Sie vollständig sind. Das liegt schon sehr lange zurück.
Okay, das ist nicht schlimm. Ich kann mit Ihrem Haus als Kontaktieren und ich kann fragen.
Kontakt aufnehmen? Okay, Kontakt.
Ich möchte mit Ihrem Haus als Kontaktieren.
Okay. Und, Hermülla, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestartet.
Ich werde Sie körperliche Untersuchungen, also besonders natürlich Ihr Bein untersuchen.
Und ich werde auch Ihr Körpertempore und Vitalparameter wie Herzfrequenz, Atomfrequenz messen.
Dann werde ich gegebenenfalls Ultraschall des Beins durchgeführt.
Und ja, ich werde auch Blut abnehmen.
Nach der Untersuchung werde ich mit Ihnen darüber sprechen.
Und bis die Untersuchung-Ergebnisse vorliegen, sollen Sie bei uns überwahrung bleiben.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Muss ich die ganze Nacht hier bleiben?
Ich würde schon gerne nach Hause gehen.
Ich glaube, es dauert eine Stunde bis der Ergebnis vorliegen.
Nach dem Ergebnis vorliegen können wir noch mal sprechen, okay?
Okay, Frau Doktor, ich muss sagen, Sie machen einen sehr netten Eindruck.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Ja, bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Unterzahnungsamt.
Komisch gleich.
Vielen Dank.
Okay.
Herr Dr. Anfraud, Sie haben Schwierigkeiten beim Laufen?
Schwierigkeiten beim Laufen?
Ja, hatten Sie.
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie solche Beschwerde schon einmal erlebt?
Sie meinten, ob ich das früher schon einmal hatte.
Ja.
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay, Frau Doktor, Sie haben einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Entschuldigung, baş ich?
Erzählen Sie mal, Frau Doktor, wie bist du?
Okay, herr logo tun tak, mein Name ist Gürbüs.
Ich habe gerade einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Und ich würde den Patienten vorstellen, wenn Sie sein hätten.
Herr Oberar.
Herr Oberar, Sie haben einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Danke schön.
Herr Müller ist 52 Jahre alt, ein Hund aus 20 Kilogramm schwer und 1,76 Meter groß.
Hauptsache.
Herr Müller ist seit, also...
Ein sehr adipöse Patient, ja?
Genau, stimmt.
Herr Müller steht sich wegen seit 1,5 Jahren bestehend
unter den Schenkel-Ödemen vor.
Und der Patient hat auch eine große Wunder im Unterchenkel bemerkt.
Und die Wunder riecht schlimm.
Und der Patient hat erst seit, dass die Beschein werden,
in der letzten, besonders drei Tagen, verschiedene Mörthaben.
Und der Patient beschrieb...
Der Patient hat Schmerzen also.
Genau, der Patient hat auch Schmerzen.
Und die Schmerzen bestätten im Ruhs-Urstand momentan seit drei Tagen.
Und der Patient beschrieb die Wunder, Kuristik, Heil und Gelb.
Der Rant von der Wunder ist gerötet.
Und der Patient klagt über Bein-Ödeme im linken Ganzen unter Schenkel.
Und er teilte mit, dass er müde ist.
Und die Wunder ist ungefähr 10 cm groß.
Ja, genau...
Und die Wunder wurde verneint.
Als der Patient seit 1,5 Jahren leidet er an Arterelle-Hypertonie.
Und seit 5 Jahren leidet er an Diabetes Melitus.
Und der Patient gab an, dass er nicht regelmäßig seinen Harfsarzt besucht.
Und er nimmt die Medikamente regelmäßig nicht.
Also das ist ein sehr inkomplanter Patient.
Ja, stimmt.
Und der Patient wusste auch, die Namen von Medikamenten nicht.
Und als Operationen wurde bei ihm Kuristik-Tomy ungefähr vor 5 Jahren durchgeführt.
Und bei ihm sind keine Allergien und Verträglichkeiten bekannt.
Und der Patient wusste nicht, ob er eine Erkrankung haben.
Ob seine Erkrankung haben.
Und er ist nicht geimpft.
Ja, genau.
Und der Patient, der die Erkrankung haben.
Also, ja.
Als Differenzial Diagnose-Common.
Das ist der erste Mal zu sagen.
Peripheral-Arterelle-Ferschlusskrankheit.
Das ist auch eine Insuffizie.
Das ist eine Diabetes-Fus-Inbetra.
Und das ist der erste Mal zu sagen.
Und das ist eine Insuffizie.
Und die Nierenwerte.
Ja, genau.
Ich werde auch Sonografie des Beins durchführen.
Besonders duplex Sonografie ist wichtig bei diesen Patienten.
Ich muss auch plastische Schirurgontag aufnehmen.
Okay.
Erst mal die Wunde an.
Und ist das Bein auch gerötet?
Ja, das Bein ist laut den Patienten überwärmt.
Und ja, gerötet.
Woran denken Sie dabei, wenn das Bein stark gerötet ist?
Entsündungskanal.
Denken.
Ich wusste das nicht.
Die Kollegin, die Hautentzündung.
RCP.
Jawohl, ein RCP.
RCP, genau.
Kann man denken.
Und ich kann auch Abschiedsricht nehmen von Wunden.
Das sind die Mikrobylob gesehen, genau.
Also, wir denken an RCP.
Woran denken Sie noch, wenn das Bein geschwollen ist?
Schmerzhaft ist.
Sie wollen ja ein Duplex machen, was wollen Sie mit dem Duplex ausschließen?
Ja, genau.
Perifera arteri, leferius, tranchait, kanan.
Und das TFT kanan ausschließen.
Eine tiefe Beinbenendromose, natürlich.
Was fehlt Ihnen noch ein, differential diagnostisch?
Ein Lymphedem.
Ein Lymphedem, ja, einseitig, aber gut kann passieren,
ist übergewichtig.
Philebotrombithis, oder ich wusste das nicht genau.
Phibithis.
Ja, aber das ist nur eine leichte Entzündung.
Das scheint ja schon sehr fortgeschritten zu sein.
Pyrdämie, man muss jetzt sich schauen, ob unter der Kruste
eventuell Eiter vorliegt und ob das sogar bis runter auf den Knochen geht.
Wie nennt man das, wenn der Knochen mit betroffen ist?
Osiumelitis.
Genau, das heißt, Sie machen auch eine Röntgenaufnahme.
Genau.
Ja, GGBNSFAS, Kamanao, CT, Duschwür, Peranlis.
Geht auch, ja, eins nach dem anderen, genau.
Sehr gut, haben die Kollegen noch Fragen.
Ja, was machen Sie noch mit den Patienten?
Ein Patient, der hat ja wohl einen schlecht eingestellten
oder gar nicht eingestellten Diabetes.
Ja, ich muss erst mal die Medikamente einstellen.
Diabetes.
Wir schauen mal, wie lange die hochte Entzündungsparameter,
wie lange die Blutzuckerwerte macht.
Und Hemoglobin A1 ist wichtig.
Das ist diese Langzeitblutzuckerwerte.
Wie die Entzündungsparameter lieber nieren werden.
Da sind entsprechend Kamadan, eine Antibiosuverschreibung.
Wir werden uns die Wunde genauer angucken
und die Wunde dann versorgen.
Da holen wir die Wundmanagerin dazu.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wunderbar.
Es ist ein Ulkoskohl bei Diabetes.
Wahrscheinlich hat das der Patient nicht bemerkt,
dass er sich da am Unterschenkel verletzt hat.
Wahrscheinlich hatte eine Polyneuropathie,
höchstwahrscheinlich Diabetes,
hat sich verletzt
und die Wunde hat sich dann nicht abgeheilt
und ist dann immer größer geworden, bis das jetzt
sich verschlimmert hat
und eine Erisipäe draufgesetzt hat.
Die Idee mit der Untersuchung nach PAVK ist richtig.
Was würden wir diesen Patienten als Erstes geben?
Medikament, meinst du?
Ja, mit der Schmerzmittel- und Antibiotika
oder Verordnung.
Was geben sie für eine Medikament?
Merbewegung und Blutzuka.
Nicht laufen, was geben sie als Schmerzmedikament?
Welches Schmerzmedikament geben sie?
Man kann mit dem Tomisor verordnen.
Neuer Gen,
oder Diplofenac,
Nirenwerte abfragen.
Ja, genau.
Mit Neuer Gen ist nicht weit,
solange keine Allergien hat.
Welches Antibiotikum verordnen Sie?
Sie machen erst mal nichts Falsches. Das ist gut, das ist gut.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Wunderbar.
Gut, Frau Dr. Gewöster, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht. Die Aufnahme war in Ordnung. Die Übergabe ist okay. Sie sind sehr nervös und aufgeregt im Hektisch, glaube ich.
Das ist alles sehr gut. Wunderbar.